[Music]
hey Colonel Brian here with a Halloween
edition of clueless gamer
today I'm going to play and rate some
scary games here to help me as always is
my friend Aaron blare hey Aaron hello
how's it going don't ask if you don't
care okay what are we doing for
Halloween we're gonna like you said play
some scary games but the scariest games
are on the computer to do this I thought
also it might be fun if we shut off all
the lights and play in the dark to get
it a truly immersive experience we
should maybe this games
what did you say mersive immersive well
first I said mersive but then I realized
I messed up why am i working with you
it's gonna get real real scary well yeah
if you want to be scared we should play
in the dark yeah that's why you had to
say okay this massive experience will
miss your list okay let's play this is
called what's this game called so the
first game we're gonna play is called
slender slender and the idea doesn't
sound scary slender with slender slender
is it's about Slenderman and the
Slenderman is a very tall slender man
who chases you through the forest and
tries to kill oh my god very small and
slender near a pine grove this is
actually a scary game she used to chase
me through the woods whenever I took his
yogurt he had the kind of the fruit at
the bottom here are your buttons yeah
you're gonna want to don't talk to me
like I'm really stupid
what all right so W moves you forward oh
I have this w sure what means forward
forward
w what means back Bob ass okay starting
game okay got my flashlight
yep looking around all right this is
actually kind of cool so we're just
trying to collect 8 pages you see the
Slenderman turn the other way around
away why do I fear the Slenderman he can
kill so it's a game that's biased
against people with control over their
caloric intake it's the Slenderman is
evil
I made a runner oh is this okay the
walking yeah you can run
yeah just shift and w oh yeah of course
well that's intuitive that's not running
this is called running yeah this guy is
fat Slenderman
this is not an in-your-face action game
I have to tell you no are you scared
right now I would say is boredom count
as scared no boredom is the opposite no
then I'm not scared I'm bored
under man who made this game
what's this a European game no European
games Europeans sometimes it is an old
folktale the Slenderman was scary but he
is slender this is the woods and he's
tired what is he gonna children he takes
away their chestnuts
the chestnuts they get Donna Lukey the
Maggie day oh that's a European truck
[Applause]
special effects there are no special
effects who made this game I mean some
guy made the game yeah I know so I wish
he had teamed up with one other guy okay
what do we would have playing next
alright so we had a poll and the fans
voted and this game won it's called
amnesia the Dark Descent so this game
it's 1839 you find yourself in a Old
Prussian Castle you have no memory your
mammy's you have no map I have no memory
I just woke up oh and you know your name
is Daniel I have amnesia but I know it's
1839 my name is Daniel and I'm in
Prussia yes those are things that if you
have amnesia the first questions they
ask you is what year is it what's your
name and where are you if you can answer
those who don't have it
so basically you were this dudes
henchmen guy and you tortured all these
people I was a dudes henchmen guy well
so this guy should go to college dude
should go to one to college and graduate
yes you're a dudes henchmen guy glad you
didn't write the first page of Moby Dick
dude I'm an Ishmael guy
oh wait what's that what's that guy to
get them that's a monster you want to
stay away from yeah that's scary
finally something happened okay what
game is this
all right this game is called outlast
brand-new it just came out it's pretty
freaky you play a reporter who's gone in
to this asylum to document it using your
video camera okay so now we're just
trying to make our way out of the asylum
all right now we're gonna crawl oh oh
yeah oh my god yeah
who is this guy we don't know it's just
some crazy inmate Susie I have to I'm a
little scared mostly by I'm pretty sure
that's lead paint on the walls one ship
that is a toxin I went to a summer camp
like this I swear to god this is exactly
like the camp I went to in freedom New
Hampshire ah you know what
I'm gonna guess he's not gonna make it
we're gonna climb up into that vent
there we go
you know what this looks like exactly
like my colonoscopy footage that's
exactly what it looks like there's the
polyp
alright go to that door click left click
alright never mind corner we're just in
the corner now we're just in the corner
well aren't you so here we go your stick
your steering oh alright cool this way
you guys Oh dumbwaiter get in there oh
yeah good job that was great thanks that
was really this is the visited evil mad
doctor what is his specialty was he an
osteopath what it collects body parts
why isn't he what pants that's a weird
look that's not sanitary he was keeping
that blade in a urinal what's he doing
is cutting up some of our fingers now
[Applause]
look at well you know what
not fingers you use a lot you know what
it could have been worse look at the
sunny side of life when life gives you
lemons you make a lemonade alright so
now we're just gonna try to escape from
this doctor yeah let's get away from the
doctor we can get out this way Oh nope
that's locked let's just hide under bed
let's just hide under bed it's too late
for that
Oh
once you're in a room with him and just
sees you you can't just crawl under a
bed
he sees you just killed I'm tired of
this guy right exactly doctor with no
pants something you know just I don't
mind that he has no flesh or these a
murderer but put some pants on yeah God
say yeah yeah yeah yeah wait
[Music]
Oh
that's not the view I wanted look at
this now we're making german porn oh you
know what this is a scary game that's
the scariest thing I've ever seen
so how would you rate these games
slender and Misha and outlast ok a
slender man I don't understand
Slenderman it's a walk in the woods and
then you see a rather physically fit
trim guy and then the lights go out
no amnesia forgettable outlast is
fantastic love this game on a scale
let's see it's a Halloween
so if bad is this reaction and really
good is I would give outlast
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]